sur tout le monde sait ce coup ci on se
revoit aujourd'hui pour la présentation
de ma pas coach abel et chinois sont
mises à la cannelle alors qu'est ce que
c'est une bague chanel basse et une
seconde chaîne doit être vivre à rien
dans mon cas cheveux claude plein de
vidéos dans la vraie vie et aussi des
fois des ans plus tard il avril et oui
mon jeu et aussi à laquelle que les
moments de jeu et quelques trucs et
filles qui me sont arrivées dans les
jeux ouais un truc on s'en fout quoi je
vais arrêter de casser les couilles
bref quoiqu'il en soit je vais commencer
par présenter parce qu'on a peut-être
certains d'entre vous ou certaines qui
ne s'appelait tissu jeunes ont lu qu'un
pseudonyme internet squeeze cet homme
fait des vidéos sur internet qui sont
plutôt hilarante
c'est pour ça qu'il a un peu de succès
webb à la barre je n'ai balco du succès
des doigts les célibataires mais c'est
personnel ça te dit tu te taire chausse
du 42 fait environ un mètre
soixante-huit h 15 ans et demi à temps
mais c'est pas la caméra qui sont situés
autour de moi bref j'espère que cette
idée vous plaira je viens de ce qui est
comme une sauterelle et que vous serez
nombreux à me suivre tous les jours car
sur cette chaîne j'essaierai de claude
une vidéo tous les jours ou tous les
deux jours
savary ramener en tout cas j'ai claude
rey beaucoup plus de vidéos que sur ma
chaîne principale car il n'y aura pas de
montage à faire ou presque ce sera des
vidéos brut prise avec mon super
téléphone portable est la matrice mais
tu vois la ferme et wab en l2 en tout
cas j'espère que vous serez donc
nombreux à vous abonner et à suivre ces
vidéos qui seront dits core de machines
principal mais qui seront tout aussi
bien
si vous aimez celle de ma chaîne
principale ou presque et puis ben voilà
une annotation à s'afficher au niveau de
ma tête comme ça vous aurez plus qu à
cliquer dessus et allez vous abonner sur
l'autre sur machines sous l'ère abonnez
vous cinq ans après que vous avez tout
ce qui à ce stade la vidéo va s'habiller
chose après en soirée les gens se
retrouvent donc très bientôt sur cette
chaîne sur moder moi je vous dis à
bientôt j'espère que vous serez nombreux
à adhérer au projet et à venir me suivre
sur cette prochaine
en attendant je vous dit ciao portez
vous bien peace and love garde la gym et
aurier mois
[Musique]
un tsunami
m
mais ça